حي مدينة غزة الذي كان يُعرف سابقًا باسم
إيليل، تحولت الرمال إلى
رماد، ويستعيد سكانها ما في
وسعهم وهو ليس
كثيرًا، وتواصل إسرائيل قصف القطاع،
ويقول
سكان البنية التحتية لحماس، في حالة صدمة، ويسألون
لماذا تزوجت هذا العام، ويقول لي
ماذا؟  هل فعلت ما فعلناه، لقد
دمرت حيًا بأكمله،
يقول إنه لم يطلق
صاروخًا أبدًا في هذه واحدة من أكثر
مناطق الأرض كثافة سكانية على وجه الأرض، القنابل التي
تصطدم بالأحياء المزدحمة
نادرًا ما تفرق بين مقاتل ومدني،
عدد القتلى يرتفع كل
ساعة  في حين أن مستشفيات غزة
مكتظة بالجرحى، بما في ذلك
الأطفال الرضع الذين تبلغ أعمارهم حوالي 40 عامًا، فإن 30٪ من سكان
غزة تقل أعمارهم عن 15 عامًا وفقًا
لوكالة المخابرات المركزية، وتفيد وزارة الإعلام في غزة
أن ما يقرب من 170 مبنى قد تم
تدميرها وتضرر أكثر من 12000
ساكن
عشرات  فر الآلاف من
منازلهم بحثًا عن ملجأ،
وتحولت مدارس الأمم المتحدة إلى
ملاجئ، وتم إغلاق فرن في هذا المخبز في
مدينة غزة، والعديد من الرفوف
الفارغة، وكانت الحياة هنا صعبة بالفعل،
والآن يبدو المستقبل أكثر قتامة من
أي وقت مضى، وستستغرق غزة 5 سنوات لتربيتها
رأسها بعد هذا يقول اه وبعد 5
سنوات ستكون هناك حربين أو ثلاث
حروب أخرى إنها
كارثة ووسط كل هذا في
مكان ما في غزة فقط حماس تعرف
أين يوجد أكثر من 100
أسير إسرائيلي المصير
مجهول بعد ظهر الثلاثاء إسرائيل ضربت
غزة فقط الميناء المستخدم بشكل أساسي  من قبل
الصيادين بينما أطلقت حماس في نفس الوقت
وابلًا هائلاً من الصواريخ
باتجاه
أشالون
تقترب الهاوية من بن ويدمان سي إن إن
القدس